compte tenu de son état de santé il est
peu probable que Pierre Palmade soit
placé en détention provisoire
aujourd'hui les juges vont s'appuyer sur
l'article 144 du code de procédure
pénale la courbe de Paris vient donc de
décider de placer Pierre Palmade en
détention provisoires avec mandat de
dépôt exécutoire autrement dit avec
effet immédiat moi quand j'étais à la
santé je suis sorti
j'ai fait un infarctus de l'intestin
qu'on n'avait pas décelé et tout d'un
coup j'avais tellement mal tellement mal
tellement mal qu'on a fini par m'envoyer
à kochard à côté de la santé et là le
professeur a fait ses examens m'a dit
vous restiez 24 heures de plus et vous
étiez mort vous sortiez dans un sac
pendant que la décision de mes tantôt
elle était en délibérée l'AVC il tombe
quand même un point nommé bon il était
pas si grave que ça puisqu'il est déjà
sorti de jointes
diplomatique
des médecins ne peut pas être mis en
cause après qu'est-ce qu'on a décelé un
cancer des poumons elle a été opérée
cancer des poumons depuis 48 heures je
peux vous le dire
cancer du pancréas à part ça ma femme
n'était pas malade du tout non non et
j'ai vu dans les réseaux sociaux
des qui disaient mais qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait la Calais en prison etc chaque fois
qu'il y a ce genre d'affaires
people derrière par définition le riche
et quelqu'un de mauvais qui non
seulement vole les pauvres mais leur
veulent du mal donc là il y a cette
c'est en résonance avec tout ce qui se
passe sur la haine des milliardaires la
haine des gens qui ont de l'argent tout
ça finalement c'est quelque chose de
très incrusté dans la société française
il arrive dans certaines affaires
judiciaires que les gens se découvrent
tout à coup de très graves maladies à
l'approche de leur procès mais là je
pense que franchement on peut pas jeter
le doute sur le ce qu'on dit les
médecins
possibles Olivier les gens qui
voudraient le voir clouer au pilori du
coup il trouve quand même que la
concordance des choses
merci beaucoup chère Thomas d'être venu
sur le bateau c'est à vous vous restez
encore
donc c'est pas grave
Bruno
moi c'est Nicolas
[Rires]
si vous habitez pas loin de Paris ou à
Paris même Benjamin faites attention
faites très attention quand vous sortez
de chez vous ouais c'est histoire de
cette internaute elle ouvre la porte
j'habite à Paris elle ouvre la porte et
vous allez voir ce qu'elle découvre en
ouvrant la porte
voilà alors bonjour
des dizaines de zombies mais genre
partout partout dans la rue des zombies
pardon tu as quel âge je peux pas te
demander ça non c'est pour ça si vous
faites copines ça c'était 3G tout c'est
déjà de vous voyez tout ça c'est quoi là
je dois pour toi pour ce tutoyer
non évidemment c'est un tournage c'est
la série The Walking Dead ah enfin c'est
un spin-off comme on dit c'est une
version dérivée du succès regardez de
hausse que ça donne c'est assez
horrible c'est à dire qu'ils ont refait
des décors alors il y a des mauvaises
langues qui disent que dans certains
quartiers de Paris vous avez déjà un
décor de The Voice en bas vois
actuellement en haut voit adolescent ce
filtre qui fait perdre une vingtaine
d'années et la dernière tendance sur Tik
Tok et ils sont nombreux à avoir
succombé à la tentation de se revoir
plus jeune parfois avec émotion
cette mère et sa fille deviennent
copines d'école le temps d'un filtre
d'autres sont moins convaincus comme cet
homme qui n'a pas récupéré sa chevelure
d'antan par immédiatement de Botox pour
la détendre voilà c'est pas grave être
âgé ça arrive à tout le monde même moi
j'ai commencé à manger que tu es dans le
visage donc tout va bien Asma on se
détend Patrice
jusqu'à boire des seaux d'eau
alors que 2022 a été l'année la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée en France le
ministre de la transition écologique
prévient la tendance devrait durer et
même s'aggraver
on se parle on est déjà 1,7 degrés
d'augmentation des températures par
rapport à l'air pré-industrielle en
France on va aller vers 2,8 32 à
l'échelle mondiale selon le nu selon
GIEC ça voudrait dire au moins 4 degrés
en France 5 ans déjà que Gauthier Hugues
testent ces panneaux solaires
rétractables sur une parcelle de sa vie
avec sa disposition en fait le but c'est
de récupérer le climat qu'on avait il y
a quelques années les panneaux protègent
la vigne du soleil en été et en hiver
permettent de gagner un ou deux degrés
contre le gel il maintient également
l'humidité dans le sol alors même qu'il
n'a pas plus depuis une trentaine de
jours la France elle utilise 2% des eaux
les eaux usées c'est en gros quand tu
tires ta chasse d'eau ce qui se passe
derrière en gros on retraite et on
refoue dans la rivière en Espagne c'est
26% en Israël c'est plus de 50% quoi
pourquoi
l'eau qui sort de tes chiottes
il faut traiter ça peut pas devenir de
l'eau d'irrigation pour l'agriculture un
scénario a plus 4 degrés d'ici la fin du
siècle l'annonce a surpris alors que
l'objectif réaffirmé pendant les cops a
longtemps été de circonscrire la hausse
à 1,5 degrés 4 degrés de plus cela
signifie plus de canicule plus
d'épisodes de sécheresse plus de feux de
forêt moins de neige autant de
changements qui risquent d'avoir
d'importantes conséquences sur des
secteurs comme le tourisme l'agriculture
l'urbanisme ou encore la gestion de
l'eau à Dubaï tu as la plus grande ferme
verticale du monde immense 30 000 m² de
surface elle produit un million de kilos
de légumes par an en plein désert on est
en plein désert on utilise quasiment pas
d'eau on est capable de produire des
légumes voilà pas mal au Japon au Japon
aujourd'hui tu as des marques comme
Panasonic ou Toshiba qu'on connaît pour
leur télé leur ordinateurs portables ils
se mettent à faire pousser des pommes de
terre et des salariés
et vous savez ce qui va se passer et
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre
d'eau précieuse puisque avant la fin du
siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis